2000 personnes étaient attendu
aujourd'hui à tour pour le 77e congrès
des maires d'indrloire 240 maires du
département se sont déplacé à l'appel du
président de l'Association des maires de
France le maire de Fondette Cédric des
Olivera de sujets majeurs ont été
discutés le manque de moyens des maires
mais aussi l'augmentation des agressions
dont ils sont victimes l'objectif
interpell la justice mais aussi
Dominique fort ministre délégué chargé
des collectivités territoriales et de la
ruralité elle était présente cet
après-midi Sébastien Branger était sur
place
madame la ministre vous nous avez dit
plein de choses qui nous vont et
pourtant je pense qu'il nous
manque une chose
majeure la confiance c'est par ces mots
que la ministre des collectivités
territoriale et de la ruralité a été
interpellé par les maires d'andrlois en
effet ils voient tous leur dotation
globale de fonctionnement et les
investissements baissés alors même que
la ministre ne parle que des
augmentations alors oui vousz raison
l'augmentation des coûts d'énergie fait
en sorte que pour nos maires les budgets
sont difficiles à boucler malgré
l'argent que l'État injecte mais
simplement nous faisons des économies au
niveau de l'État très significatif nous
avons 3000 milliards de dettes beaucoup
de frais financers liés à cette dette
nous voulons réduire cette dette malgré
ça on investit comme vous le voyez dans
nos collectivités locales mais oui on
demande aussi à nos collectivités
locales de faire des effort un discours
qui passe mal chez les mares ruraux en
particulier pour qui cette augmentation
ne compense pas l'inflation ni la hausse
des prix de l'énergie bah j' dirais que
c'est c'est c'est dramatique pour nous
parce que avec la hausse du coût des
énergies des salaires dont je suis très
heureux pour nos agents mais bon on a ça
nous a coûté encore un peu plus de de 10
points et le problème c'est que c'est
non compensé par l'État contrairement à
ce que les ministres disent ça c'est
totalement faux qu' viennent nous voir
et on on leur montrera ou démontrera que
effectivement on on a plus les
ressources qu'on avait auparavant autre
thème porté par le Congrès la violence
envers les élus selon lins 15 % des
maires ont un sentiment d'insécurité
c'est c'est un climat général avec une
évolution de la société qui est qui est
dangereuse parce que quand on s'attaque
au ma on s'attaque aussi au fondement de
la République et donc cette évolution
elle est dangereuse pour tout le monde
pour toute la société je crois qu'il
faut vraiment que tout le monde en ait
conscience de
sur cette question hormis un
renforcement au niveau pénal la ministre
a annoncé la création d'un numéro de
téléphone dédié au maire pour un
accompagnement
psychologique